*musique un peu stressante*
Alors comme ça moi, il y a des gens qui me ressemble moi ?!
BAH TU VAS VOIR TOI !!! TU VAS VOIR!
Plus rien ne va dans l'égo de Squeezie, et vous savez que cet égo est énorme
Je reçois depuis quelques temps de plus en plus de tweets qui disent ...
"hé regarde il te ressemble trop on dirait un sosie hé  hé"
ÇA TE FAIT RIRE ?! Tu sais ce que ça fait de plus se sentir plus unique sur cette planète ?! Hein !?
Les amis, aujourd'hui j'en ai marre de ne plus me sentir unique.
De me dire que d'autres gens sont très très proche de moi physiquement. Ça me dérange!
Alors on va regarder un peu tout ces gens là qui me ressemblent,
Ou alors c'est moi qui leurs ressemblent, on sait pas d'ailleurs.
Et on va trouver l'ELU, celui qui me ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau.
Que ma mère pourrait confondre avec moi-même
Pour se faire Clément a mis au point un algorithme ou un effet au montage on sait pas ce que c'est.
On sait pas si c'est réel ou un effet du montage
Qui nous donnera un peu le pourcentage de ressemblance
Et je vous le dis, je vous l'assure, d'ici la fin de la vidéo on aura trouvé LE MEC qui me ressemble le plus!!!
De tout Internet, et si y en a un qui me ressemble vraiment beaucoup, je le contacterai pour voir si il peut pas venir ici  au studio...
et je lui parlerai etc... pour créer du contenu pour vous divertir et a la fin, hop! je le buterai comme ça je redeviendrai unique!
c'est bon ! Excusez moi je suis tout excité mais...
c'est vrai que ça me travaille un peu pour de vrai cette histoire
c'est parti, ça commence, ici !
avec Le Monde à L'Envers qui me dit: "Desolé..."
j'espère que vous êtes désolé! oh c'est horrible
le plus gros point en commun que j'ai avec cette homme c'est un petit défaut...
(effet) DRING!
La calvitie. Algorithme ! dit nous la verité sur cet homme !
j'ai craché !
34 % c'est pas dégueu, c'est pas dégueu !
j'ai envie de tenter un truc est-ce que
si on fait un photomontage de moi sur sa tête, c'est drôle ! aller on teste maintenant. Le résultat...
*claquement de doigt*
Personne ne veut smacker cet homme
Je trouve que Antoine te ressemble beaucoup sur certains angles surtout les yeux
Alors attention, le mot "surtout" et le mot "que" ne sont pas les mêmes. Y'a vraiment QUE les yeux
Oh shit
Rencontre de deux sosies
A-Alors ça je l'avais vu passer mon gars c'est fabuleux
Regardez comme on dirait Bigorneau et Coquillage
mais dans une autre dimension mec c'est fou ou pas ?
Je ne sais pas qui sont ces gens mais lancez une chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle "Bigorneaux et Coquillages 2"
Ils pourraient faire une vidéo à notre place sur la chaîne "Bigorneaux et Coquillages"
que personne ne verrait rien.
-Bonjour !
-Yes !
Bienvenue sur la chaîne de Bigorneaux et Coquillages !
T'as un truc avec Tommy Cash, on mettrait ton visage ça serait presque similaire ou pas...
Oh ! Je vois un peu, je vois un peu ce que tu veux dire ! Encore une fois
le meilleur moyen de savoir si on se ressemble c'est de mettre mon visage
à la place du sien et de voir si ça nous trouble beaucoup ou pas. Enfin je trouve !
Alors on le fait maintenant et...
Alors non et en plus c'est... ça fait... c'est très creepy ! Allez on passe à la suite !
Petite ressemblance vite fait. Alors
physiquement ou dans le contenu ? Popo auto-clash !
Alors lui je l'ai vu revenir mille fois aussi ! Je sais pas qui c'est mon gars !
Mec c'est vraiment un mix JOYCA ET MOI !
Vrai ou faux ?
"Tiens j'ai trouvé ça sur une pub Instagram pour monoprix"
C'est troublant là ...
C'est bizarre c'est comme si c'était moi qui avais fais ça,mais que j'avais pas le souvenir de l'avoir fait
mec c'est troublant sa mère !!!
attend on va la retrouver cette pub monoprix
*Chanson de la pub*
HAHAHA !!!!
EH il y a un petit air en vrai !
AH non il est plus stylé...
*rire* En vrai il est un peu plus stylé je trouve
Eh ce jeu m'amuse, la chasse au sosie. Je vous jure, à la fin de la vidéo, y'a un sosie qui vient
Squeezie alias Drago Malefoy. Vraiment, pas du tout
J'aurais adoré être là à Serpentard
Jouer avec ma baguette mais non, ça ne marche pas. Vraiment ça match pas du tout
Alors ça aussi, J'EN AI MARRE DE CELUI LÀ ! Ça, c'est celui qui m'a le plus poussé à faire cette vidéo
Ce mec est égérie pour une marque qui apparemment fait
Des ciseaux et des coupe-ongles,
ce qui est plus stylé que d'être Squeezie
Et du coup chaque abonné que j'ai, quand il passe à la pharmacie et qu'il voit ça, il le tweet et il me fait :
"Eh regarde c'est toi je t'ai vu derrière une lime à ongles héhé"
Alors j'ai aucun problèmes avec le fait qu'on croit que je suis égérie pour des coupe-ongles,
Mais JE SUIS PAS ÉGÉRIE POUR DES COUPE-ONGLES OKAY ?! C'est pas moi !
La barbe c'est bon mais c'est les cheveux le problème
Y'a un petit air ! Si je regarde comme lui, en mode vilain garçon
*Musique*
Non, c'est non putain !
"Une petite ressemblance"
*musique stressante*
Mais!Y 'a un petit truc là.
Même si sa barbe est plus belle que la mienne...
Regardez, en plus, tout le monde me mentionne dans ses commentaires *rire*
C'est génial! C'est vraiment un truc qui le suit. Il doit me détester
Serait-ce toi, Alexandre, mon sosie officiel?
Je vais contacter Alexandre. Si ça se trouve, il me déteste. Tout le monde lui dit tout le temps "eh, tu ressembles à Squeezie"
Ça le fait chier et il a une haine incroyable envers moi. Il a acheté des posters de moi et il joue aux fléchettes dessus peut-être...
Bref, j'vais le contacter
Et s'il est chaud, dans quelques secondes, nous allons traverser cette porte ensemble, et nous serons frères jumeaux.
C'est parti
*Bruit ouverture de porte*
Alexandre : Heyyyyy
Squeezie : Heyyyyyy
Lucas : J'suis avec mon sosie Alex. Comment ça va?
Alexandre : Ça va et toi?
Lucas : Alex, merci d'être venu
Alex : Y'a pas de soucis
Lucas : Tu es très beau. Je te l'ai déjà dit?
Alex : Bah, comme toi
*rires*
Lucas : Ecoutez, la blague, c'est que quand il était en bas, et que j'suis allé lui dire bonjour, quand j'l'ai vu en bas et tout, ça m'a fait bizarre,
Y'a comme eu un truc bizarre entre nous. J'ai l'impression de l'avoir déjà vu .
Lucas : Alors, moi je trouve qu'on se ressemble beaucoup.
Alex : Moi aussi
Lucas : Ok
Ce qu'on veut savoir, c'est si t'es mon sosie officiel, et pour ça, on va faire un petit test très simple :
Je viens de tweeter que je vais sur Omegle pour rencontrer les gens,
sauf qu'en fait, c'est toi qui va être ici, à ma place, et qui va dire bonjour aux gens
Et on va voir combien de temps ça va durer avant que les gens grillent la supercherie
Je t'ai prêté un t-shirt à moi, et je t'ai prêté une casquette à moi.
Comme ça, y'a vraiment tout pour que les gens confondent.
Mais oh putain,  les tatouages! Les tatouages, on est cons!
Le petit K-way, comme ça, ça cache les tatoos, sinon, on est baisé.
Comme t'es dans mon décors,
Alex : Ouais
Lucas : et que en plus, t'as un t-shirt que j'ai mis dans des vidéos, y'a tout pour que les gens te confondent avec moi.
Est-ce que ça va marcher? On va voir...
*musique*
Lucas : Eh ben non! C'était mon sosie et t'as rien vu, t'as rien vu venir!
*rires*
Lucas : C'est mon sosie. Avoue, t'as pas reconnu?
Mec : Mais qu'est c'est que cette merde?
*rires*
Fille : Mais nan !
Alex : Mais si!
Fille : Mais nan!
Lucas : mais si!
Alex Mais si!
*rires*
Fille : C'est quoi ça wesh?!
Lucas :C'est géniaaaal, ça marche de ouf!!!
C'est mon petit sosie.
Fille : Avoue, c'est tes trucs de magie
Lucas : Ben non! Quoi? Quels trucs de magie?
Mec : Oh
Alex : Salut!
Mec : Bonjour
*rires*
Lucas :Ça marche tellement bien! C'est incroyable!
mec : Carrément. De ouf
Lucas : C'est mon sosie
*musique*
Mec : Bonjour
Lucas : Bonjour
Mec: Oh waaaw!!! Oh la vache!!!
Lucas : Ca marche bien, il est tombé dedans bien! C'était drôle
Mec : Putain, j'me disais qu'il y avait un truc... oh la vache, les batards
Mec : Allô?
Alex : Allô
Mec : Squeezie?
Il est où ?
Mec : En vrai, ça fait pas longtemps que je cherche...
Alex : J'ai une surprise
Lucas : Hey ça va? C'est moi Squeezie!
Mec : Mais quoi?!
Lucas : C'est un sosie, regarde, c'est Alexandre, je te présente Alexandre
Alex : Bonjour
Mec : Bonjour Alexandre. Mais mon Dieu
Lucas : Est-ce que t'as une chaine Youtube?
Mec : euuh, moi ouais *c'est* SilverCoque
Lucas : Et c'est quoi ton prénom?
Mec : Antoine
Lucas : Alexandre,est-ce qu'on irais pas s'abonner à la chaine d'Antoine?
Alex : Bah si
Lucas : Allez, SilverCoque sur Youtube, pur la petite pub. C'est pour toi, c'est pour toi Antoine.
Antoine : Blague à part, j'ai mon pote là,
Lucas : Ahah, la surprise!
Antoine : Il fait du dessin, il s'appelle BiggerbilleDraw et il est hyper talentueux, il mérite  beaucoup
Lucas : c'est bon? Niveau pub on est bon?
Antoine : Ouais, c'est bon, on est nickel
Lucas : okayyy, bon parfait, et bien à bientôt
*musique*
Fille : C'est une blague?
Lucas : C'es Alexandre, c'est un sosie.
Alex et Lucas : ben non
Lucas : T'y as bien cru?
Fille : Non, sérieux?!
Lucas : Bah oui *rires*
Fille : C'est une blague?!
Lucas : Mais nan!
Lucas : Fin oui, on fait une blague, mais on est vraiment là
Est-ce que t'as cru que c'était moi au début ici?
Fille : Oui, au début oui, j'me suis dit "mais on dirait pas trop lui, mais on dirait lui, c'est bizarre"
Lucas : A chaque fois y'a un truc qui change quand même
Fille : Merci, salut
Lucas : chao
Alex : Oh
Alex : Allô?
Lucas : On t'endend pas...
Lucas : Même quand ils ont pas de micro ça marche *rires*
Mec : Salut mec, ça va?
Alex : Qu'est ce que tu fais?
Mec : Ben, c'est mon cosplay
Lucas : Ouais mais attend, c'est pas un cosplay de ouf que t'as là...
Mec : C'est pas vrai!
Lucas : On t'as eu ou pas?
Mec : Gros je m'y attendais pas du tout ...
Lucas : Ah, c'est génial! Et il est parti, il s'en va
*musique*
Alex : Qu'est ce qu'il y a?
Mec : C'est pas réel
*en même temps*
Lucas : Bah c'est pas réel, c'est pas réel, faut lui dire
Alex : ban non, non
Lucas : C'est pas réel
Lucas : C'est un sosie. T'y as cru! On T'a vu
Mec : totalement
Mec : Squeezie?
Alex : Oui?
Mec : Non, c'est un fake
Lucas : Ben non, c'est pas un fake gros, tu vois bien mec
Mec : Non?
Lucas : C'est un vrai sosie regarde; je peux lui toucher le bras, lui toucher la joue, c'est un vrai sosie. Y'a pas de fond vert
Lucas : mais il crois que je l'arnaque! Ben je t'arnaque pas, c'est la vérité!
Mec : Putain! Allô?
Lucas : Oui? C'est Lucas, bonjour
Mec : Oh punaise! J'croyais que c'était un fake!
Lucas : Ben non, ya pas que des fake
Mec : Ah ben y'en a, y'en a, c'est ça le problème.
Lucas : C'est pas un fake, c'est un sosie, c'est pas pareil
Lucas : Elle est bien cette technique quand je parle et que tu fais genre. Ça marche trop bien!
Mec : Nan! Naaaan! C'est pas vrai! T'es pas le vrai. Fais un cœur avec tes mains
Mec : Oh putain mais...Ça fait littéralement 30 minutes que je te cherche
Lucas : Aaaah... La patience porte ses fruits, par contre, c'est pas moi qui te parle en faite. Moi je,
Mec : What the fuck?!
Mec : C'est quoi ce bordel?!
*rires*
*musique*
*BIP*
Lucas : Bon, Squeezie, c'est terminé
Lucas : Et j'ai envie de faire un épisode 2 direct. C'est trop drôle
Alex : Ah ouais
Lucas : Maintenant, les gens sauront après la sortie de la vidéo et ils vont nous griller...
Lucas : Bon ben, n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu. Ca y est, j'ai trouvé THE SOSIE! Attention, le insta de Squeezie 2 s'affiche ici
Lucas : Tu sais quoi? En ce moment,  j'ai la flemme de faire des photos pour mon insta. Fais des photos de toi, tu me les envoies et je les mets sur le mien.
Alex : Ouais, bah pas de soucis,
Lucas : Et je fais genre c'est à moi. ok?
Alex : Ouais, pas de problème
Lucas : Ok pas de soucis, c'est cool
Lucas : Ouais voilà, c'est cool. On se rend des petits services entre sosies
Alex : Ouais ben voilà, y'a pas de soucis
Lucas : Bah les amis, je vous fais des gros bisous, merci Alex, c'était trop bien. J'ai ri, c'était trop bien, merci
Alex : Super
Lucas : Alex, il a pris le train, il m'a répondu, il m'a dit "ok, j'prends le train" et il est venu, c'était son jour de repos et il est venu là
Lucas : Donc j'aimerais un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour Alex
*Bruit d'applaudissements*
Alex : Merci, merci
Lucas : A bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien, au revoir
Lucas :Et bonne chance pour trouver votre sosie... Moi j'ai trouvé le mien, mais pas vous
*musique outro*